TOP OF THE DIVISION.
OUR STARTING GOALTENDERS.
THE SAME FORWARD L.
>> ONE OF THE FOCAL POINTS ALL
SEASONCK FOR EIGHT
THE 15TH YEAR
PHYSICALLY ENGAGED CHARTS THAT
WE HAVE SEEN FROM GREENWAY THIS
EASE IMPAIRED COULD YOU WANT
FIALA HAS FOLIGNO DRIVIN
>> 1017 SINCE IT AROUND FOR
SPURGEON.
TRIES TO
AND THIS IS FOLLOWED THAT TO A T
.
UCR
THAT GOOD NAME IN VANCOUVER BRO
THE WILD CONTROL THE DRAW WALL .
THE HEAVY NATURE OF THE FIRST
PERIOD CONTI PRIMER. CHANGING.
IT IS HELD BY TALBOT.BY GREENWA.
BRODIN, BACK TO ZUCCARELLO THAN
OFF
HIS COAT OF FIT PROTOCOL BREAK
AND
MERKLEY PITLICK WILL START THE
SECOND PERIOD IN THE PENALTY BOX
. THE LEADERS IN THE ROOM
HAVE BEEN CONSISTENTLY ALL YEAR
WE'VE  FIALA.
FIALA DOWNLOAD.
ERIKSSON EK.
TIED UP BY LIKE THE WILD MIGHT
OVER PASSING A BIT TOO MUCH TO
GIVES IT TO DUMBA.
LEAVES IT FO
HE DROPS IT BACK.
ERIKSSON EK WINS THE DRAW TURNA.
HE POPS IT OUT OF THE STICK,
DISHES RIGHT ACROSS ANDHIS CARE
ON THE RIGHT POINT.NET.
15 IN THE POWER PLAY,  IS AGAIN
, JUST ON HIM.
THE WHOLE TIME
THING 1 AS WE
HEAD INTO THE THIRD
THE ICE.
PROBABLY THE BIGGEST IT WEAVE
SERENE HIM THROW.
>> AND MISCOMMUNICATION IN FRON
OF THE NET AS YOU MENTION